(bouncy, energetic Georgian folk music)
(bouncy piano music)
- [Narrator] Georgian
National Dance is a folk dance
comprised of strong, athletic movements
from the male dancers and
floating, effortless movements
from the females.
The unique choreography combines
folk with classical ballet
and modern dance, and the company’s best
are part of Georgia's
original professional
dance company, Sukhishvili.
- Our dance company
exists more than 70 years
and my grandparents
created this dance company.
It was wholly due to them
that the Georgian dance
became so popular in my country.
Now our dance company
is more than 100 dancers
and a live band.
- [Narrator] The company has
traveled around the world,
and since it's creation,
has performed in front of
over 50 million people.
But preparing to take
the stage takes years
of rehearsed practice.
- [Nino] They need a lot of training,
because we perform very difficult dances
and complicated movements.
We dance on the toes and
they have nothing inside.
It's like a thin leather boot.
- [Nino] We use daggers and
swords through the dancings
and they need to have
a good fighting skills.
- [Narrator] To be a Sukhishvili
dancer is a huge honor
in Georgia, and with a
school of over 3,000 dancers
in training, the future
of traditional Georgian
folk dance is bright.
- I hope that Georgian dance
will be popular always,
because it's very patriotic.
We do our job with a great love.
We dedicated our lives to this.
(chiming)